this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode he's taking another
look at the weapons of fallout new vegas
but this time with twist they're all
mods i instinctively want it to look
exactly like it did in the movie this is
a problem this is my problem not the not
the mods problem but i do understand and
appreciate why you would make it fit
because a pulse rifle in fallout makes
no sense if you want to see more of
jonathan reacting to fallout guns make
sure to subscribe as we've got three
videos on bethesda's iconic franchise
and if you'd like to help out the royal
armouries museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video right over
to jonathan
well if you'd have told me that this was
an official fallout gun i would just
assume that i missed it in the game
because it's very much in keeping
ludicrously large lots of pipes and
bells and whistles sticking out of it
with that sort of retro 50s esque car
parts look to it i like this quite a bit
i'm not sure the significance of the
word charge in little lights at the back
there i don't know if that's there all
the time or if i missed something i like
the fact it's got a badge on it that
again looks like a car badge and the
name slightly comedy name of the the
mertelizer is uh is also a nice touch
the ominous crackle of electrical energy
and the cool sound effects what's not to
like
oh
now this one's a little bit more cursed
i think it's fair to say no offense to
the to the creator of it but i suspect
they would agree with me now this is the
browning high power which is in the base
game and everything else i think is
additional it has a wooden butt stock
now the browning for hp 1935 gp 1935 did
have the ability to fit a shoulder stock
to it yeah so far so good extended
magazine if you watch uh footage or see
pictures of the iranian embassy siege in
1980 with the sas they had browning high
powers with i believe there's a 25 round
extended magazine sticking out of them
that's not a new thing for the high
power either and it's a very common
thing available for pistols across the
board today the muzzle compensator
getting maybe a bit more exotic it's
that's more of a a race gun thing so a
competition pistol for shooting
accurately but quickly keeping the
muzzle down and then actually fitting
with that somewhat is the
sight rail which is a fairly classic
ipsc style open class setup ish
from maybe the 90s with a rail
attached to the dust cover of the frame
for the pistol and then allowing this
which allows the slide to operate
underneath it uh underneath the actual
rail that's attached to the side mount
all of these elements
or two or more of these elements might
work together arguably the thing that
kind of breaks it
is the knuckle duster attached to
the trigger guard there's really no way
to use that practically as a knuckle
duster it could only function as
just an impact weapon
and your gun is already an impact weapon
especially with that compensator on the
end so i don't know if they've modded
this to be customizable or if this is
the standard look of this weapon if this
is the default configuration of the
weapon the knuckle duster doesn't make
much sense i think someone just thought
let's add everything we possibly can
think of to the browning
some of you will know or remember that i
do really like the mp5 as a classic
modern firearm now this for within the
limitations of this game's graphics this
is this is a solid effort does seem to
be missing the ejection port and
therefore the the visible bolt inside
the weapon which we should we should be
able to see on the right hand side the
overall type is of course the mp5k and
it's looking good the front grip doesn't
look quite right from memory i didn't
grab one to refer to today but the stop
at the front of the front grip is the
proportions don't look quite right i
think they're working within some strict
polygon limitations here and i think
they've done a good job and there is
some some weathering on the edges now it
looks like there's weathering on the
edges of the trigger mechanism housing
which is not correct but they may have
been referencing the hollywood converted
mp5 such as we see in die hard which
uses the
hk94 civilian version of the mp5 from
back in the 80s with the barrel cut down
and a few other components changed
around and they have this metallic
trigger group with the plastic pistol
grip like a g3 this is basically the the
more modern
polymer trigger group of an mp5 or an
mp5k but as i say they seem to have a
dividing line on the graphics between
the polymer bit and what appears to be a
metal bit but i may be reading too much
into this
so this this submachine gun although
it's being used as a machine pistol here
really folding stock i very much doubt
there's there's the mechanic to let you
unfold that but it is it is a submachine
gun on the face of it this thing this is
the volca mpl aesthetically it fits the
wasteland i think in terms of rarity in
our uh reality at least you're not going
to find volatile mpl's lying around i
don't think okay so on the
manufacturer's name issue uh the in-game
name is the volta vault tech smg so
actually this apparently is made by the
same company as it was in our reality
it's just that vault-tec have sponsored
it or it's a particular variant that
they adopted as a standard armament of
course they didn't in the base game but
let's pretend that they did but speaking
of sponsorship nuka-cola sponsorship
there's a sort of medallion in the left
side of the trigger mechanism or the
grip frame and there's another nuka-cola
kind of what looks dangerously like a
charm attached to the front left and the
the only place this thing lets itself
down really sorry guys is this is the
random stuff wrapped around the grip
syndrome this is just a video game thing
that constantly is done i get why but
it's not necessary if you're going to do
this make it necessary so have the grips
missing or have them visibly damaged
maybe the screws have fallen out and
you're holding on the grip panels with a
piece of whatever that is not everything
you design has to have a function but
for nerds like me we get excited when it
does
okay so here's a gun that um arguably
doesn't make sense in the fallout
timeline although it is arguable but it
does in the spit it's very much in the
spirit of fallout with the term we use
in in my world is craft produced
previously homemade but this is a this
is several notches above homemade this
is uh it's more of a small factory
product because this is as the name
actually tells us the chechen balls or
boughts forgive my pronunciation but
this is a very nicely done rendition of
this design lots of detail the knurling
on the on the uh barrel nut and on the
end cap wouldn't expect to see that i'd
have thought that would get fudged into
some lines or some dots or something but
lots of detail including the wear
there's attention to detail in terms of
the different how the different parts
are made so turned bits of steel versus
sheet or box section steel the wood
looks like it could be wood knowing how
old this game is and what the
limitations or having an idea of what
the limitations are in modding this i'm
really impressed with this one in
particular
[Applause]
right this is this is going to need i
hate this word but it's going to need
some unpacking so we've got a type a
type 3 ak kalashnikov rifle which is not
in the base game so that's a mod in
itself and what looks
close to a pbs1 style sound suppressor
which is a real suppressor for the ak
and then this insane
magazine now it's not actually as insane
as it looks because something very close
to this i don't think this is quite
right in terms of how it attaches at the
front was as far as i know legitimately
experimented with in um soviet russia
but not on the ak it was on the akm i
think it was a hundred rounds but i'm
not entirely sure on that and it did
actually have to clip to the front
of the rifle now the bit and the reason
the reason it's different is this
doesn't seem to attach to anything so
the curvature must be wrong here or the
barrel length is wrong because it should
be flush with
the muzzle and it should have a sheet
metal bracket on the what would be the
lower back bit of the magazine but here
is just all back to front and upside
down and that would fit over
the muzzle i'm not even sure how it was
how it was attached to the weapon i've
only ever seen a black and white picture
of of this now for pretty obvious
reasons that was never adopted but
it's based on far as i know a genuine
thing or it's a very convincing hoax
from the 60s or 70s
as much as i can't condone the uh
wanting the slaughter of domesticated
animals that there's a graphic
demonstration
of what a mine on a stick might do if a
mine on a stick were a plausible
weapon which i don't think it is this
appears to be i think it's an anti-tank
mine of some sort that has been sort of
lashed to the end of a pool cue creating
a sort of really badly balanced javelin
and then
it sort of has some somehow it has an
impact fuse now i definitely wouldn't
want to have one of these thrown at me
in case it did somehow initiate if it's
at all plausible the user would be at as
much risk of it going off as the victim
would be at risk of receiving the
resulting explosion the mines require
quite a lot of direct pressure depending
on whether anti-personnel or anti-tank
let's assume this is some sort of
anti-personnel mine therefore if you i
mean the way it's sort of lashed on
would be is pretty questionable you
probably you probably set it off in the
course of creating it i don't know
and then you'd have to have sort of try
and hit the target square on to actually
get it to reliably or at all go off it's
it's a it's a fun idea it's maybe the
wrong wrong phrase
i can't help thinking about how you'd
really do it but uh yeah not not really
recommended
[Music]
instantly mixed feelings here because
it's a pulse rifle so on some level i i
have to appreciate that and i do i think
this is deliberate they haven't just
changed it for sort of for the hell of
it or for copyright reasons i think this
is what would a pulse rifle look like if
it had been invented in the fallout
universe and if that was the design
intent i think they've done a great job
i instinctively want it to look exactly
like it did in the movie this is a
problem this is my problem not the not
the mods problem but i do understand and
appreciate why you would make it fit
because a pulse rifle in fallout makes
no sense they have interestingly they've
not included the thompson gun in the
design that as a lot of you will know
the pulse rifle was built fundamentally
on a thompson submachine gun heavily
disguised but you can still see that bit
of receiver the copying handle i will
just say that the the label on the side
that says fragile handle with care i
don't know if that's an in-joke or
something but um the pulse rifle is
meant to be uh
in the movie a robust military weapon
and the way they made these props was to
they made them perfectly and then simon
atherton the armorer threw them into the
corner of a room repeatedly until they
had that battered worn look that you see
in the movie like they've been around
for 10 years at least that that
conflicts slightly with the fragile
handle with care sticker
i must admit my initial reaction to this
was yikes and that's because i saw the
the bolt rather like the infamous
trailer for a recent call of duty game
the bolt actually clips straight out of
the back of the gun although in that
case they've designed it to look like it
should come out of the gun here it seems
to be maybe this is a work in progress i
don't know but it clearly should not be
coming out the back of the gun if it did
there'd be a big hole and then we
wouldn't see the yeah actually ppsh
shaped this is the top cover latch
actually that's that's there on the
model and we wouldn't see that there'd
be a gaping hole now i think this is
meant to be a homemade take on the
purpose so i can't be too critical of it
i don't think you would bother to share
if you were making a gun from scratch
you would not try to replicate slavishly
the stamped steel construction of the
body of this gun
there wouldn't be any any advantage to
doing that unless you just wanted it to
look like a paper shell in which case
make it look more like one but we've got
a sort of wasteland looking improvised
steel butt stock and pistol grip on that
replacing the traditional wooden stock i
guess my main issue with this design
is
the magazine so they've gone for a
version of the standard curved box
magazine that was introduced later on to
essentially replace the less reliable
and much more expensive drum magazines
of the publisher but this magazine
design is not amazing unfortunately it's
um weirdly open i mean that magazine
body would distort very easily because
it's sheet metal with no support down
the side it's cut open far too much and
it has no space in the bottom for the
magazine spring so it would not function
as shown
there's a lot been said about the sa-80
l85 a2 in this particular form so doing
as i often do
a straightforward visual comparison here
with the real thing a lot of the detail
is right but unfortunately it's too
short quite dramatically too short
actually but i think it's only in the
barrel so it's almost like it's got the
well or something closer to the carbine
the l22 a2 carbine length barrel fitted
although it's probably not a match for
that either so the flash suppressor
should not
start at the front of the rail system as
you can see there's a good
two and a half slightly more than that
inches of barrel before you get to that
because the sa-80 has always had a
full-length
20-inch m16 length barrel in
a short overall package which was really
the main thing about the sa-80 right now
this is the this is a game engine
problem but when the player [ __ ] the
weapon he does so up here as though
there's a
cocking handle or a charging handle
up at the front of the gun there is not
of course
one of the sort of ergonomic quirks of
the sa-80 is that you have to flip the
gun over and [ __ ] it with your left hand
over the gun the game clearly doesn't
permit anything like the proper drills
for this rifle and so they've had to
they've had to fudge the reload they
have at least done it on the on the on
the right-hand side of the gun which is
where it should happen and it happens
very quickly so it's barely noticeable
especially in first person
i like this design
quite a bit this appears to be entirely
original there's a lot of attention to
detail here in that it's using what look
like improvised components so threaded
bits of pipe random bits of wood that
have been finished into into the shape
you would need them to be a magazine
from something else uh maybe maybe it's
meant to be a grease gun magazine given
that this is i think 45 acp pistol
cartridge uh the pistol cartridge is a
great choice for
relatively lower pressures so you're not
having to worry as much about the gun
blowing up i think the only failing of
this gun is failing of a lot of
real-life crash-produced firearms which
is that they don't pay enough attention
to the sighting system now the designer
of this has in game terms because it has
a rear aperture sight i would guess it's
meant to be repurposed off a real gun
but there's no front sight to align it
with so whereas in the game it's well
you've already got the reticle to aim
with so kind of irrelevant anyway but
cosmetically it works as a site
intuitively it works as a site because
you have something to look through but
in real life you'd have no way of
aligning that shot and it could go
almost anywhere in a pretty wide cone
somewhat constrained by
your cheek being on the stock and the
whole being front of your eye it's going
to reduce the cone somewhat but not
ideal for the work that's gone into this
design if it was real you would want to
design in a tall post front sight to
match up with this and then try to zero
them so that your shot your point of aim
coincides with your point of impact at a
known range and then you would know
roughly where to aim because as it is
you've got really no idea luckily
i guess we have vats
i think there's a movie where the rock
fires a browning m2 50 cal from the hip
suffice to say that is not plausible in
real life well it is if you're the size
of the rock you can physically do it but
only with blanks the recoil generated by
actual 50 bmg rounds is like even here
you cannot keep that thing on target for
more than one shot i would i would
suggest uh please don't fight me the
rock i have some issues as well with um
okay i mean the feed mechanism is
essentially or feed arrangement so
basically as they would be if this was
mounted uh in fact the recoil lack of is
basically as though this was mounted to
a
fixed pedestal mount and therefore all
the recoil forces are going down through
the pedestal into the floor of a vehicle
and therefore the gun wouldn't move the
firing
mechanism they have put a pistol like a
sort of vertical pistol grip on top of
the top plate of the gun that's fine in
terms of that's not the top cover that
lifts up because you wouldn't want it on
that it's on the actual fixed top plate
of the gun in the way of the sights but
you can't use the sights anyway the
problem is how that would interface with
the actual
firing mechanism you would have to
create a linkage a hole in the top of
the top plate and some sort of linkage
to reach the actual trigger mechanism
trying to work out how this would work
in real life as a fool's errand because
it can't be done
not the first weapon i think of when i
think fallout universe this is the the
heckler [ __ ] vp70 so a few issues with
this thing the player's arm i haven't
spoken about this is a problem with
several of these mods is in the geometry
of everything is such that when you
radically change your model like this
fixed poses of the character are going
to be a problem so inevitably in like in
this case the forearm clips right
through this unusual thumb hole stock
arrangement absolutely not not the the
designer's fault they've got they've got
detail on here so
on this side of the gun is the fire
selector so putting the stock on the gun
turns it into a machine pistol pulling
up on the lever puts up this um
sort of disconnector overrider is really
what this is the slide comes back it
runs over
that
and does not disconnect the trigger
from the rest of the gun which means
that it keeps firing however it's not as
simple as that because this is a
three-round burst only mechanism so
it actually counts
how many shots you fired and then
disconnects the trigger so you only get
three rounds out of this so the rate of
fire on this is too low what that boils
down to and it should only be spitting
out three rounds per pull of the trigger
why am i not surprised that someone has
created a pancorp jackhammer for
new vegas this is this is um one of the
infamous guns that is more of a video
game gun than it is a real gun even
though it was designed as a real gun and
produced our prototypes were produced
but suffice to say that
drum fed
bullpup shotguns in general have not
really caught on and this thing sadly
hasn't either but um the designer could
have some certain amount of pride in the
life it's had in video games you know
represented here basically as it's as it
the real thing it's got the correct name
it's not got a fictional name it hasn't
been changed we don't have because
there's three of them in the world we
don't have one
but um i think that's a a pretty close
approximation of the design now i would
say that the the reload and animation of
this is a bit fudged but actually it's
it's no more fudged really than than the
real gun because you had to partially
disassemble the gun to replace the the
drum magazine so you once you'd fire the
shots in the cylinder once you tried
those shots that was it really it is
automatic or was designed to be
automatic so that depiction is correct
but if you weren't if you're thinking
god that's a really low poly not very
good model yeah the the gun itself is a
low poly gun
whipper
now i think this one has to just be a
bit of fun i believe there is um there
is one gameplay mechanic where this
would play a role in that if you have a
essentially a concealed weapon you go
into a something like a casino you get
to keep that weapon whereas you would
have to hand in
your conventional weapons so presumably
what it was invented to allow which is
which is a nice bit of creativity from
memory there's at least one attempt at a
spy camera with a gun built into it it's
not something we have in our collection
but i i believe that was tried at least
once in the cold war period perhaps
that's where they got this from or at
least the idea for this we we even get a
scope view that looks somewhat like a
camera viewfinder which is a nice touch
if you'd like to support our work here
at the royal armouries museum we have
the link in description for how to do
that otherwise check out our various
social media platforms our youtube
channel which i'm fairly heavily
featured on if you like that sort of
thing failing that i'll see you again
next time thanks again guys
[Music]
[Music]
you